et nous sommes à présent avec le
président de la protection civile des
yvelines arnaud cette valve bonsoir
bonsoir
alors on vient de voir cette action de
soutien pour cet agriculteur dès que vie
mais la protection civile des yvelines
est aussi en renfort du samu notamment
vous êtes mobilisés en fait sur
plusieurs fronts pendant cette crise
sanitaire exactement habituellement on
fait les gardes auprès des sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines précisément sur
l'ensemble de ce corps de versailles et
dans cette crise sans précédent pour la
france on a décidé conjointement avec
les sapeurs-pompiers de mettre à
disposition des équipes du samu une
équipe de jour comme de nuit qui se
relaie comme plusieurs robes dior en
france puisque en france c'est à peu
près 150 ambulance et la protection
civile
en fait partie vous êtes aussi mobilisés
dans les hôpitaux vous avez une des
bénévoles qui sont directement dans ses
hôpitaux pour orienter informer les
personnes qui se rendent dans ces
hôpitaux exactement on a contractualisé
avec le groupement hospitalier
territorial qui s'occupe des hôpitaux
ont de plusieurs hôpitaux du nord du
département et on a des missions très
spécifique sur l'hôpital de poissy sur
l'hôpital de mantes la jolie
l'action alidou c'est à la fois de
pouvoir accueillir et orienter les
personnes soit qui se rendent aux
urgences avec le dispositif au sein des
postes médicaux métier poste médicalisé
et ensuite on a tous une grande partie
sur autre chose par exemple sur
l'accueil très simplement dans ma à
l'accueil principalement de développer
là pour pouvoir aller pour orienter les
personnes sur sur différentes choses et
on parlait des bénévoles la protection
civile fonctionne aussi grâce à ses
bénévoles se sont combien de bénévoles
qui sont en ce moment mobilisées dans le
département des yvelines
alors on a une quarantaine de bénévoles
et on a également activé une réserve
départementale de protection civile qui
est coupée près de soixante bénévoles
supplémentaires le plan de la crise donc
on est sur un potentiel sur les 8 215
bénévoles consultables sur sûr aussi
bien sur les tâches administratives mais
également sur des missions bien plus
précise et vous êtes appuyé sur votre
socle de bénévoles déjà existants ou est
ce qu'il ya de nouveaux bénévoles qui se
sont fait connaître aussi pour apporter
leur pierre à l'édifice en sept ans
cette crise on a eu énormément de
demandes spontanées je remercie aussi
les personnes qui ont pu le faire aussi
bien à travers notre hymne national
aussi départementale
les sites du gouvernement il ya beaucoup
de personnes aussi bien à domicile sur
des missions et qui sont quand vous avez
pu voir aussi avec l'agriculteur des
missions logistiques donc on a on a
besoin de personne et ces personnes ne
sont pas ne sont pas inutiles dans notre
organisation et c'est très important
pour pouvoir protéger nos millimes
comment vous êtes vous adapté pour mener
à bien justement ces actions est aussi
peut-être protéger vos bénévoles qui
sont sur le terrain comment vous êtes
vous organisé alors sur la protection
déjà on a sollicité nos différents
partenaires par exemple pour avoir une
protection un sas de protection à
l'intérieur de notre ambulance qui nous
permet de pouvoir à la fois protéger la
ultime et protéger l'ensemble de nos
équipes ont remercié également nos
partenaires comme le samu qui nous met à
disposition des équipements de première
deux points des équipements de
protection individuelle plutôt et à
toutes
tous ces équipements en fait concourent
à la sécurité de nos bénévoles mais
également des réservistes puisque même
s'ils sont les services pour nous ils
font partie intégrante de la protection
civile et on doit faire également
attention à eux est quelque chose
d'important on développe aussi des
techniques comme on a pu le voir par
exemple tout au long de l'année on donne
des cours de technique d'optimisation du
potentiel technique militaire de
stratégies mentales pour gérer le stress
la fatigue et les émotions et on leur
permet aussi gratuitement de pouvoir
continuer à se sensibiliser comme ça
parce que pour nous c'est très important
il puisse durer maintenant mais aussi
après tout en gérant cet aspect fatick
qui qui est très très important et
primordial pour une dernière question on
a constaté que le nombre
d'hospitalisations et de réanimation est
en légère baisse dans le département
qu'avez-vous envie de dire aux yvelinois
qui peut être voit que les beaux jours
reviennent qui se disent peut-être la
crise est derrière est passé qu'est ce
que vous avez envie de leur dire aux
yvelinois pas de continuer à rester chez
eux où on sait que c'est compliqué de
continuer à suivre les recommandations
de la préfecture du gouvernement de
respecter parce que c'est eux qui savent
ce qu'il faut faire et même nous mêmes
les bénévoles qui n'ont pas de mission
lié à la protection civile à un instant
t il reste à leur domicile la preuve
pour pour moi qui reste confinée
moi-même pour pouvoir continuer à gérer
les équipes au quotidien donc restons
sérieux faisons tous et restons tous
citoyens merci arnaud cette valve et je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
la protection civile des yvelines